hello and welcome back this week you
learn about object detection this is one
of the areas of computer vision that's
just exploding and it's working so much
better than just a couple years ago in
order to build up to object detection
you first learn about object
localization let's start by defining
what that means you're already familiar
with the image classification task where
an algorithm looks at this picture and
might be responsible for saying this is
a car so that was classification the
problem you learn to build a neural
network to address later in this video
is classification with localization
which means not only do you have to
label this as say a car but the
algorithm also is responsible for
putting a bounding box or drawing a red
rectangle around the position of the car
in the image so that's called the
classification with localization problem
where the term localization refers to
figuring out where in the picture is the
car you've detected later this week you
then learn about the detection problem
where now there might be multiple
objects in the picture and you have to
detect them all and localize them all
and if you're doing this for an
autonomous driving application then you
might need to detect not just other
cause but maybe other pedestrians and
motorcycles and maybe even other objects
so you see that later this week so in
the terminology we'll use this week the
classification and the classification of
localization problems usually have one
object usually one big object in the
middle of the image that you're trying
to recognize or recognize and localize
in contrast in the detection problem
there can be multiple objects and in
fact maybe even multiple objects of
different categories within a single
image so the idea is you've learned
about for image classification will be
useful for classification with
localization and then the idea is you
learn for localization will then turn
out to be useful for detection so let's
start by talking about
with localization you're already
familiar with the image classification
problem in which you might input a
picture into a confident with multiple
layers so there's a confident and this
results in and this results in a vector
features that is fed to maybe a soft max
unit that outputs the predicted class so
if you are building a self-driving car
maybe your object categories are they're
following where you might have a
pedestrian or a car or motorcycle or
background this means none of the above
some of this no pedestrian your common
no motorcycle then you may have an
output background so these are your
classes they have a soft max with four
possible outputs so this is the standard
classification pipeline how about if you
want to localize the car in the image as
well to do that you can change your
neural network to have a few more output
units that output a bounding box so in
particular you can have the neural
network output for more numbers and I'm
going to call them B X B Y B H and B W
and these phone numbers parameterize the
bounding box of the detected object so
in these videos I'm going to use the
notational convention that the upper
left of the image I'm going to denote as
the coordinate 0 0 and the lower right
is 1 1 so specifying the bounding box
the red rectangle requires specifying
the midpoint so that's the point
B X comma B Y as well as the height that
would be B H as well as the width B W of
this bounding box so now if your
training set contains not just the
object class label
which union that took us trying to
predict up here but it also contains
four additional numbers giving the
bounding box then you can use supervised
learning to make your algorithm outputs
not just a class label but also the four
parameters to tell you where is the
bounding box of the object you detect it
so in this example the idea px might be
about 0.5 because this is about half way
to the right to the image B Y might be
about 0.7 since that's about you know
maybe 70% of the way down to the image B
H might be about 0.3 because the height
of this red square is about 30% of the
overall height of the image and BW might
be about 0.4 let's say because the width
of the red box is about 0.4 of the
overall width of the entire image so
let's formalize this a bit more in terms
of how we define the target label Y for
this as a supervised learning task so
just as a reminder these are our four
classes and the new network now outputs
those four numbers as well as a class
label or maybe probabilities of the
class labels so let's define the target
label Y as follows
it's going to be a vector where the
first component PC is going to be is
there an object so if the object is
classes 1 2 or 3 PC will be equal to 1
and if is the background class so if
it's none of the objects you trying to
detect then PC will be 0 and PC you can
think of that as standing for the
probability that there's a object
probability that one of the classes
you're trying to detect is there so
something other than the background
class next if there is an object then
you wanted to output B X B Y B H
and BW the bounding box for the object
you detect it and finally you if there
is an object so if PC is equal to one
you wanted to also output c1 c2 and c3
which tells it is it the class 1 class 2
or class 3 so is it a pedestrian a car
or a motorcycle and remember in the
problem we're addressing we assume that
your image has only one object so and
most one of these objects appears in the
picture in this classification with
localization problem so let's go through
a couple examples if this is a training
set image so that is X then Y will be
the first component PC will be equal to
1 because there is an object then b XB y
bh + BW will specify the bounding box so
your label training set
we'll need bounding boxes in the labels
and then finally this is a car so it's
close to so C 1 will be 0 because it's
not a pedestrian C 2 B 1 because it is a
car C 3 will be 0 since it's not a
motorcycle
so among C 1 C 2 C 3 at most one of them
should be equal to 1 so that's if there
is an object in the image 1 of this no
object in the image whether we have a
training example where X is equal to
that in this case PC will be equal to 0
and the rest of the elements of this
will be don't cares so I'm going to
write question marks in all of them so
this is a don't care because if there is
no object in this image then you don't
care what bounding box the neural
network outputs as well as which of the
three objects you want C 2 C 3 it thinks
of this so given a set of labeled
training examples this is how you it
construct X the input image as well as Y
the class label both images where there
is an object and for images where there
is no object and
these will then define your training set
finally next let's describe the loss
function you use to train the neural
network so the ground truth label was y
and in your network outputs some Y hat
what should be the law speed well if
you're using squared error then the loss
can be y1 hat minus y1 squared plus y2
hats minus y2 squared plus dot dot plus
y8 hat minus y 8 squared notice that Y
here has 8 components so that goes from
sum of the squares of the difference of
the elements and that's the loss if y1
is equal to 1 so that's the case where
there is an object so y1 is equal to PC
right so PC is equal to 1 that is if
there is an object in the image then the
loss can be the sum of squares over all
the different elements the other case is
if y1 is equal to 0 so that's if this PC
is equal to 0 in that case the loss can
be just y1 hat minus y1 squared because
in that second case all the rest of the
components are don't care us and so all
you care about is how accurately is the
neural network outputting PC in that
case so just a recap if y1 is equal to 1
that's this case then you can use the
squared error to penalise squared
deviation from the predictor than the
actual outputs for all eight components
whereas if y1 is equal to 0 then you
know the second to the eighth components
that don't care so all you care about is
how accurately is your neural network
estimating y1 which is equal to PC and
just as a side comment for those of you
that want to know all the details have
used the squared
just to simplify the description here in
practice you could use you can probably
use a log likelihood loss for the C 1 C
2 C 3 e to the softmax output one of
those elements usually you can use
squared error or something like squared
error for the bounding box coordinates
and then for PC you could use something
like the logistic regression loss
although even if you use squared error
or very work okay so that's how you get
a neural network to not just classify an
object but also to localize it the idea
of having a neural network output a
bunch of real numbers to tell you where
things are in a picture turns out to be
a very powerful idea in the next video I
want to share of you some other places
where this idea of having a neural
network I'll put a set of real numbers
almost as a regression task can be very
powerful to use elsewhere in computer
vision as well so let's go on to the
next video